Joe Biden officially announced that he's
running again Donald Trump officially
announced that he's running again
in if that's the matchup who do you
think wins
if the election's held today
I think Biden
why well first of all I believe he won
last time
and if I start with the results from
2020 and I think to myself what has
happened since then that would push or
pull voters one way or the other
I have a hard time making a case that
Trump is in a better position today than
he was in November of 2020
. so that's kind of my starting point
which is it's a rematch of an election
with a known outcome
what has changed
and I can't make a case for
circumstances having changed in Trump's
favor